hello everyone this is uh andrew eid i'm
with kent scientific corporation
today we're going to be talking about
right sizing small animal anesthesia
particularly for rats and mice and other
small
laboratory rodents
if you have any questions throughout the
presentation
feel free to type them in
uh
we'll either
answer try to answer as many as we can
at the end of the program
or if there's some good ones that come
in uh we'll try to discuss them a little
bit during the program
anesthesia has been
used for last couple hundred years now
and this ends up being generally two
types of anesthesia
the
gas anesthesia or inhalation anesthesia
and injectable anesthesia
gas anesthesia has advantages over
injectables
because it's easy pretty much pretty
easy to use
you have better control over depth and
duration it's very easy to adjust the
concentration
uh almost instantaneously on gas
anesthesia
animals particularly small animals don't
really metabolize the gas anesthesia
that much it
it stays in their bloodstream
and
it is expelled through the lungs
through most of it is expelled through
the lungs so it's easy to uh for the
animal to recover and he doesn't have to
worry about the liver or other organs to
metabolize the
inhaled anesthetics
uh
inhaled anesthetics are safer for the
animal and increased the chance of
successful outcomes
which again it's because of the fast
induction and the fast recovery for gas
anesthesia
the problems with gas anesthesia
are a few one of the things is typically
you need a
some big equipment to vaporize
the anesthetic correctly
and takes time to set it up to make sure
it's all working sometimes there's a
steep learning curve
a lot of people
feel that
gas anesthesia is somewhat magical in
what it does and so they're kind of
afraid of it
and you have to make sure that your
multiple components are working well
together make sure that
the vaporizer works with the flow meter
and the gas source and
bringing it down to the animal
there's also
using the large equipment
that people people typically use there's
a big risk of
anesthetic exposure to the researcher
and staff
because
a lot of
a lot of anesthetic is wasted and often
is blown off just into the room
and typically it requires a compressed
gas source of some type
whether it's compressed air or oxygen
source to make to make the vaporizer
work
traditional
small anesthesia systems typically are
designed for humans and larger species
such as horses the same vaporizer that
people are using on a mouse can be used
on a horse or a larger animal
it's
it's all
mechanical
the
standard vaporizer that's made
besides requiring large air flows
typically weighs as it says here 35
pounds or 30 pounds and has a large
footprint on the lab bench even a
tabletop stand will have a fairly large
footprint
the weight is caused by
a heat sink that's built into the
vaporizer because as the anesthetic
evaporates it draws energy from the
environments the environment being the
vaporizer
which drops the
temperature of the of the vaporizer so
it uses and needs a big heat sink
uh of solid metal to
try to control that temperature drop
and also the problem with that uh
vaporizers typical vaporizers is that
they are agent specific so a halothane
vaporizer which people really don't use
anymore can't be used for anything else
so it's just has to be if it can be
retooled it might be able to be re
or reworked it might be able to be used
but if now
if you're using a
sibo fluorine vaporizer it can't be used
for isofluorine
and typically a high oxygen flow was
required i just
had a
an inquiry come in
just yesterday
from england in which a person for
anesthetizing a mouse uh the researcher
was using uh two and a half liters of
oxygen from per minute
uh at two percent isofluorine
concentration that's that's quite a bit
of gas
for a mouse
uh right sizing
continue
so
typically you might have this type of
setup for traditional anesthesia set up
you'll have if you're ventilating the
animal you'll have a ventilator you'll
have a
uh
if you're doing pulse oximetry you would
have
like maybe a computer with a pulse
oximeter pulse oximeter on the mouse
oxygen tank
and
it
ends up being a rather large setup
particularly in cramped laboratory
spaces
so there are other choices out there
one is the samnen suite
which
we are
which we provide to the research
community kent scientific
small animal anesthesia
you will have to just as a side note you
will have to forgive me because i was
i'm the substitute speaker so i'm not
probably as smooth as the
regular presenter but
i
am the designer of these products so
i do have a little bit of background
with them
uh our the sumner suite design is based
on the physiological characteristics of
rats and mice
the
small footprint is six pounds or less
compared to 30 pounds
it's
the same unit can use either isofluorine
or sibo fluorine or if there's another
gas
liquid
anesthetic
all we need to know is the molecular
weight and we can put it in
into the program and use that
it requires low flow and low oxygen use
and is safer
for the user
there was a
syracuse university has six of six of
these in one room
and they had been using a traditional
vaporizer set up
and were having problems with with
anesthetic uh build up in the room and
exposure to the researchers
the
they purchased six of these for their
student lab and we were told that when
their
control people came in
and tested for
anesthesia anesthetic exposure they
couldn't find any significant levels of
it with six running so it's we were
pleased to
hear that the system works on
the way the system works is based with a
syringe
syringe driven
anesthetic going into a warmed vap
heated vaporizer block so
uh the unit can take 10
anywhere from 100 microliters up to 10 a
10 microliter gas tight syringe
and
the
injection
goes into the
warming
we call it the integrated digital
vaporizer
which
uh
which injects the
isoflurane or the seal fluorine into the
warming block
the warming block has an active heater
on it electronic heater on the bottom is
temperature with a
thermostat
or actually a temperature sensor that
goes into the
microcontroller unit so that we can
control accurately control the
temperature
to overcome the effects of the about the
decrease
overcome the effects of
evaporation drawing energy from the
system
it's also uh has a dial control so it's
feels similar to a standard vaporizer
instead of trying to use a digital um a
digital type of control so with the dial
you can dial up
anywhere from zero to five percent for
isoflorine
and
zero to
eight percent for sibo fluorine
the unit also is capable it has an
internal pump so it can use either room
air or compressed gas
the
arrow here shows the align the inventory
line to an animal
and then the excretory line is for
scavenging to a charcoal canister or to
a
evacuation line
on the back there's the compressed gas
inlet and there's the outlet to the
scavenging filter
and there's also the room gas inlet
the integrated display show
shows the volume of anesthetic remaining
it shows the anesthetic percent setting
and the ch the flow shows the flow meter
we call it the minute volume because one
of the modules that can be put in here
is a ventilator and and
uh
so in a ventilator we use minute volume
as as a term for flow rate
um because it's the amount of air per
minute going out
or gas going out so we use this the
standard term of minute volume which
also shows history the last five
readings uh you can also save data to an
internal memory
and then dump that uh bring the unit
afterwards to a computer and dump the
data
to a computer
uh there's also alarms in the system
this is
this
uh photograph gives a small illustration
of what they would look like with a
mouse on a
using a nose cone
with a rubber seal on it
the
alarms can be set for low anesthetic
level it can be set for
too high of a flow rate or almost
anything that you want them to any
parameter that's inside of the unit that
the unit is detecting can be set
giving connections you can go to an uh
incubation tube
if the ventilator is installed you can
go to nose cone for the standard
vaporizer and induction chamber
typically
i like to say that
you'll use less
anesthesia in a mouse for a mouse uh
doing a full four hour experiment than
you would filling a funnel filled
standard vaporizer so typically we use
about a half ml anywhere from from 0.3
to 0.5 ml per hour for to anesthetize a
mouse
and the standard vaporizer uses much
much more than that even
10 or 10 times or more
the
vital signs monitoring during anesthesia
is particularly critical
the uh
it helps gauging the depth of anesthesia
and maintaining the animal safety
preserve preserving uh the the
excuse me
the validity of the experimental data
any and any excuse me the nih guide
uh
for the care and use of laboratory
animals recommends that pulse oximetry
be used
uh to determine
the
uh
levels of advanced anesthesia of the
animal
excuse me for stumbling over my cell
phone as i said i'm not the i'm the
backup speaker
uh
careful surgical monitoring and timely
attention to problems increase
uh
the likelihood of
uh should decrease the likelihood of
successful surgical outcome
the effects of the anesthesia of the
anesthetic but one thing we know is that
the anesthetic reduces or anesthetics
reduce typically reduce heart rate so
one percent isofluorine does does a 24
drop in 2
does a 38 drop
and some of the other anesthetics also
have even more significant drops in
heart rate
another con area of concern is the depth
of anesthesia
the depth of anesthesia must be
maintained at the proper level and to do
this you would uh
to induce the animal so the animal goes
down deep enough and then
then getting the animal on the nose cone
or intubating the animal afterwards
and to make sure that the animal stays
down
through the whole uh through the whole
surgical procedure
now there are a few things that people
use uh a toe pinch
on a on an animal to see if there's a
reflex reflex uh to see if there's a
type of
eye reflex on the animal
the one i like the best for doing uh
light anesthesia on a
on our mice
is the tail curl uh
we found that as if the animal is
getting too light on some when we're
doing our testing
their tail the first thing that the
animal starts doing is their tail starts
curling up it's
it's very interesting so
it starts getting tense and it's curling
up
and
then when we give it a little bit more
anesthesia
the tail goes down flat again
so vital signs monitoring is quite
important uh to help in making sure that
your data
is
is good because the if an app
if the animal
uh
is
out of its normal
physiologic ranges then the body
goes into other
reactions
so the heart rate and respiratory rate
may increase if the anesthetic becomes
too light
also the
heart rate and breathing might increase
somewhat if the oxygen concentration for
the animal was too low
vilestyne's monitoring preside provides
an objective measurement
of the reading besides just a subjective
reading of the toe pinch and
or the tail coil and things like that
then you have
procedure specific requirements
on things to consider
uh
you know in addition to the effects of
the anesthetic how how will your
procedure alter the animal's
physiological state
uh
anesthesia because of the
causes uh hypothermia because of
vasodilation
so it's really important to maintain the
animal at a on a warming pad
and the surgery that if your surgery
requires a long time with the animal's
body open
uh body cavity open
then there's a lot of evaporation that
that can occur
in the
body cavity
uh
a lot of evaporation from from the body
cavity of liquid water evaporation which
then cools down dries out or desiccates
and cools down the animal's
core temperature
over here next and then what is your
study study protocol involved
are you doing survival surgery obviously
if you're doing survival surgery you
have to be much more careful on on
the way you're treating the animal
so that the animal will have a better
chance of survival from the surgery
also anesthetizing multiple times
you want the animal to make sure that
they're metabolizing
the anesthetic well
and
also the cost of the animal
the animals will be
expensive animals you want to make sure
done well and are very well taken care
of
and then the i
i cook guidelines and recommendations
are also very important which brings
into the
to reduce the number of animals and to
refine your research particularly where
we're involved here
we read this before a little bit on
the na nih guide
for care and use of laboratory animals
suggesting that
for anesthesia
delivery precision vaporizers and
monitoring equipment should be used
and which is why we're discussing this
today
pulse oximetry and such
uh
monitoring animals under anesthesia
there's two way there's two ways of
monitoring the vital signs one would be
invasive monitoring uh the other way
would be non-invasive
invasive monitoring it takes a much
higher level of skill
typically
if you're going to be using a telemetry
device
that record the telemetry device
requires a very
uh drastic surgical procedure
just to implant the device
and
which has its own mortality rate
and then
we need to
also
excuse me
you also have the high cost of the
equipment
telemetry devices are rather costly to
to surgical implant and then they don't
last that long
and the other option would be to have a
direct
dwelling arterial
cannula for monitoring blood pressure
uh non-invasive monitoring
we prefer uh does not require implanting
a device is less expensive than
telemetry and can be used on the
in multiple animals
uh advances in technology allow it to be
quite accurate and consistent and
reliable
uh so some of the parameters that you
might be watching
are
temperature which is
probably the most important uh to
maintain the animal at its core
temperature
with this uh
the hypothermia is often you know occurs
as we met as we discussed
with the anesthesia
surgery requires the evaporat
requires
has evaporation of the animal body
temperature should be maintained in the
normal range
uh the best way of doing this is with
the rectal probe in the feedback loop
otherwise known as a neothermic blanket
we prefer systems that have
to maintain uh for warming the animal we
mainta we prefer systems that actually
use far infrared
radiation instead of just a higher
frequency type of radiation
in horse studies it's been shown that
the far infrared penetrates the body
penetrates up to five centimeters into
the horse muscle
so if we uh
bring that over to a mouse the far
infrared penetrates right through the
body it also has um
a lot several other nice
parameters
such as uh inducing the parasympathetic
nervous system and doing uh
increasing nitrous oxide production and
such and so it has some some benefit
other beneficial parameters to the
animal for the foreign radiation
mouse temperatures and different animal
temperatures are are here typically we
find that a mouse temperature is needs
to be
uh to work well it needs to be 30
37 to 37 and a half
next thing that you that is very
important is oxygen saturation because
as the animal breathes
is is under anesthesia its respiration
rate is also depressed
so
the
uh
as the animal breathes then it's getting
less minute volume and getting less air
so with the animals breathing room air
uh under gas anesthesia
it ends up
gasping the deeper it goes it ends up
gasping and
decreasing its respiration rate
which is very critical to the animal so
oxygen is given to overcome this if
you're not measuring so the pulse
oximetry measures how much oxygen is
carried in the blood um oxygen
saturation is determined by passing two
wavelengths
and we can
give a better
go into that deeper but looking at our
time and the things to cover i think we
don't need it
to get into that too much
uh pulse oximeter calculates the
difference between the oxyhemoglobin and
oxyhemoglobin
and newer
the newer pulse oximeters that are
designed specifically for laboratory
animals can go up to
900 beats per minute a typical
veterinary style
uh pulse oximeter
typically only goes up to 450 beats per
minute
also the sensors that are used are
specifically designed
for the mouse
the
some there are companies out there that
have tried using human size sensors on a
mouse so it requires a
good chunk of the
of the animal to be used uh so that to
determine the pulse oximetry the animal
has to be shaved and
then the
sensor applied
to the like the thigh of the animal or
to the neck of the animal something
that's typically as big as a finger
other companies other
other
devices out there are actually
specifically designed for the paw
the clip anesthesia is the the clips
with a spring-loaded clip you have to be
careful because over time the clip will
cause the continuous pressure will
cause ischemia
in the area and since you're trying to
measure the the
blood flow and the oxygen contents of
the blood
flowing past the sensor if the sensor is
squeezing too tight it's going to
uh the blood is going to go somewhere
else and so we have ischemia and you
won't be able to pick up the reading
uh
other sensors our sensors are designed
for
uh mouse paws the kent sensors and i'm
not trying to
when we looked at the system we tried to
do something that was definitely mouse
specific
so the sensors are used on the paw they
are not
they do not have a spring they have a
little rubber band around the outside
but the rubber band can be it can be
used with or without the rubber band and
you can adjust the tension on them to
get the right flow rate and also the
center is hollow work and it closes
around the outside so that the flow is
is channeled towards the middle of the
ball
where the sensors are
the oxidant the
if an animal is on room air
during gas anesthesia particularly
the
oxygen content can go as low as 80
percent because the animal is not
breathing well
gasping and
and not having a proper minute volume
uh typically
a
people will give oxygen then to the
animal
and that
overcomes the uh
the problem of low
low ventilation and brings the pulse
oximetry or the oxygen blood oxygen
content back up to 97 to 100
um so you have to be careful and if
you're not monitoring the pulse ox or
the blood oxygen level you know what
does that have affect what effect does
that have in the animals lungs
marcel the
keynote speaker
has great information on all of that
being a veterinarian from
ut
san antonio
uh so
typically people will deliver
supplemental oxygen but there is a there
is a problem particularly long surgeries
with with supplemental oxygen that we
will get to in a few minutes
the um
also the a decrease in spo2 might not be
respiratory related but it um may be
perfusion related also that because of
the
vasodilation there's
the blood flow through the appendages
aren't as great
so
when you're looking at vital signs
monitoring for the animal you should
have uh look at the whole animal and not
just
at one parameter
and
only alarms are beneficial and systems
typically cost around five thousand
dollars
uh here's some spo2 ranges
typically that are good
for the animal
another thing to monitor what you're
doing if you're doing vital signs
monitoring is is heart rate
pulse oximeter
will give you heart rate um
heart rate measured in beats per minute
the heart rate will tend to increase as
the depth of anesthesia decreases
uh pulse oximetry
sensors are able to calculate the heart
rate by by monitoring the
because it's measuring the pulses
already
so typical heart rates from a few
different laboratory animals
and as we've been as we've talked about
other too is respiration rate
both heart rate and respiration rate are
depressed
but you will find that uh
under anesthesia if the animal is on
room air it'll start gasping and the
heart rate will go up because the organs
are not getting enough oxygen
so
when you do put the animal on 100 oxygen
the heart rate will go down
and the breathing rate tends to go down
also because the animal and the organs
are not calling
for the oxygen
that's necessary
uh so respiratory rate is measured in
breaths per minute it can be visualized
by watching the chest rise and fall but
it's a subjective measurement and it's
not continuous
anesthesia depresses the respiration
rate as we've talked about uh freely
breathing subjects on room air can
easily become hypoxia we've talked about
that subjects have irregular gasping
breathing breathing patterns which we've
mentioned and oxygen
can alleviate the hypoxia but
100 oxygen is not a normal condition for
the animal
and can have some other effects uh
particularly for long anaesthetic
anesthesias
so artificial ventilation
we feel is or is a major uh component
for
well anesthetized animals and
controlling the variables of the outside
variables of the animals
because when you're doing an event
when you're doing surgery and for a
particular study you want to be able to
control as many of the variables as you
can so that you can the
research can be reproducible
so artificial and ventilation allows the
animal to breathe
at physiological rates at normal normal
rates
it allows the subject to breathe room
air so you don't have the complications
of
oxygen particularly for long-term
experiments
it allows the subject to breathe in a
normal tidal range volume
tidal volume range excuse me
uh things to look for
in an arc with artificial ventilation if
you're trying to
choose a ventilator is get a
get a ventilator that's pressure and
volume control
uh
get one that has a peep
with it
get one that has side breath insertion
that is really important because as the
animal
animals who are ventilated for a long
time either under anesthesia or
um excuse me spontaneously breathing or
ventilated can
uh have athletic uh build up
or they can become antalectic
in their lungs and this so when you
insert a side breath into the regular
breathing pattern every so many breaths
that
expands the lungs to a greater volume
redistributes the surfactant throughout
the alveoli
and gives the animal a much more
efficient breathing uh capability
uh
also the animal if the animal is lighter
the uh have a ventilator that has an
assist mold in it so that it detects
when the animal is trying to inhale and
then it will
give the animal a breath
and
also you if you're doing imaging you'll
definitely want a ventilator that
triggers
that triggers and works with your
imaging your
mri machine or something like that and
make sure it has built-in safety
parameters like it can't do over
pressure
standard
piston pumps type vent ventilators the
old type
with the piston pump going back and
forth a lot of people use those for
through the years but they've never
uh
tried never monitored the animals uh
title uh excuse me airway pressure
so
if a person
dialed in the wrong tidal volume in the
piston pump
the airway pressure would go way up and
would often could often pop the lungs
so some here are some typical breathing
rates of animals
and lastly though the
something else that you can monitor will
be blood pressure
the blood pressure obviously is the
force against the artery walls the uh
blood pressure is recorded the two
numbers the systolic and diastolic
pressures
uh
and monitoring can be invasive or
non-invasive
invasive is done through catheterization
or through telemetry
and
uh
and but it's continuous which is nice
about that
so you get a continuous waveform that
you can monitor
whereas the non-invasive blood pressure
is measured through the tail
um
the animal's temperature has to be
correct so you have to really make sure
that the animal is on a warming pad
when you're trying to take their blood
pressure non-invasively the tail
the tail on the right or mouth
specifically are used for
temper uh core temperature control
now and a blood pressure reading can be
taken every 30 to 45 seconds
and you can also get her continuous
heart rate from the s from the pulse
oximeter
greetings
the different types of methods the
one that seems to be
uh the oldest method is photo
plusesmography that's shining a light
across the tail and picking up trying to
pick up the pulsations on the other side
of the tail with the photo sensor
us people have used a piezo sensor or
strain gauge around the tail called
piezo plusesmography
and the last one is the volume pressure
recording
technique that is used with a
additional sensing cuff on the tail the
to get accurate readings from the tail
the
the body the vpr cuff is actually used
is pressurized and squeezes the blood
out of the tail and then when the blood
flows back into the tail
it
the method is mechanically integrates
the blood coming in
and gives accurate readings of systolic
and diastolic pressure
uh consider
considerations when you're selecting a
lab
a monitoring system
uh identify the parameters you think
you'll need
for the animal the study and the
protocols i
i um
i have coke
protocols and guidelines
uh how much space you're going to need
for all this equipment
and consider the future
use with animals or upgrading
for different modules
over here
um
why wouldn't you monitor animals
think about what uh
what's going on with the anesthetized
animals on a cold lab bench
and for several minutes with with no
oxygen
the body can go into
a lot of other
reactions
from these things
the
domino suite as we talked about uh
before has has additional modules that
can be added to it and does none of
these modules increase the footprint of
the system
the
with the
mouse vent
you can install automatic ventilator
which goes right inside the
mouse fence chassis
or you can install
a mouse pulse oximeter
called the mouse that and into the
sound chat
sound suite chassis
the ventilator
which is called the mouse vent is both
volume and pressure control
the
uh it's simple to set up
the system was designed to try to make
it uh tremendously easy the default
ventilation pressure is 15 centimeters
of water which is a safety parameter it
dials in so that's the maximum pressure
that the animal will get
and then
using allometric formulas the user just
has to dial in the weight of the animal
and the formulas are used to determine
what the respiration rate is and also
the tidal volume and minute volume that
the animal should be getting
then other things that the mouse vent
capabilities are is that it has
automatic side breaths you can dial in a
side breath down to every inserting at
side breath every 10 breaths the side
breath is a breath that is at a higher
pressure typically so if you're
ventilating at 15 you might have a side
breath of 20 or 25 to expand the lungs
every periodically
assisted ventilation
if the animal is
spontaneously breathing
you can still give them uh
still have them intubated and give them
a breath
every so often the triggering for the
ventilation for the assisted ventilation
occurs it either waits for an animal to
breathe
or if it doesn't receive a breath within
a certain
period of time which the user can set it
will automatically give a breath to make
sure that the animal is not
expiring dying
you can have remote triggering in or out
which is particularly important for for
imaging
and electronic peep
uh
in this illustration that shows that
that the peep here is or the p is at two
centimeters of water
peep is the peak and expiratory pressure
which is used to keep the lungs inflated
that's particularly important if you're
doing an open chest in surgery
because
uh once you breach the uh
the plural cat uh intrapleural cat
cavity where the lungs reside
then the lungs will collapse
the peep keeps the animal keeps the
lungs from collapsing
uh we had a question here is this is the
uh from
murray home at csu east bay
uh he asked is this is a zombie suite
system compatible with stereotaxic
frames yes it is it can it can be used
with any of the common stereotaxic
frames that are out there
the ventilation
uh and even better on a stereotaxic
frame is having the animal ventilated um
if i can add that
uh
integration of both ventilation and
anesthesia in one device so the
important part about this
about either way but
the besides using the standard vapor
this on using the samna suite as a
standard vaporizer
for delivering anesthesia to a
spontaneously breathing animal if you
put the
uh
if you add the ventilator module to the
samuel suite
it will uh
ventilate the animal or anesthetize the
animal at even much lower concentrations
then you use
blowing air or blowing gas past the
animal's nose
because the animal
is delivered the anesthesia that's
delivered or anesthetic that's delivered
to the animal is
only the amount
that the animal is required to keep it
under
and
so the ventilator
delivers a breath to the animal but it
goes through the vaporizer block picks
up just the amount of anesthesia and
then delivers that down the tube to the
animal so essentially you're vaporizing
at the animal's nose not somewhere
distant
and then piping it through a ventilator
to the to the animal
uh
the system can also take a mouse tap
that's built into it so besides the
ventilator you can also install the the
pulse oximeter the pulse oximeter
will measure
that slide didn't come out very well
there
but it remember measures heart rate
perfusion
uh oxygen constrict oxygen concentration
otherwise known as spo2
and
uh it'll measure respiration rate if
there's a strong enough respiration rate
on the paw so there's two sensors that
are available there's the a little clip
which has the just the rubber band on
the outside a very lightweight rubber
band
on the outside so it's not spring loaded
and it is the hinge is rather stiff so
that you can position it
and
it will it will stay there but will not
increase the pressure in the animal the
way spring sensor will or we have other
sensors for special special use sensors
which are essentially non-contact which
we call the annular sensors
which have a just a hole through them
the one on the right is a four
millimeter sensor that slides over the
animal's paw
uh
only
the possib um
this is the only pulse oximeter that
that i know of that works on the
animal's paw everything else is is
trying to use human size sensors on a
mouse
great
so we want to leave the last
15 minutes here
or anything for the for questions
we have a second question
that came in
this is from um
mara holly from the university of
lethbridge
uh the question is to use the ventilator
does the animal need to be intubated
yes the animal does need to be intubated
the
current techniques require the animal to
be intubated
i can scientifically we provide a
and other companies do too but we
provide a system that's provided
which is manufactured by a company
called biolite
which has a fiber optic
illuminator that goes down the center of
the endotrache tube
which makes it much much easier and they
have a whole system to
for intubating the animal
we really feel that
the intubation of the animal
particularly for longer procedures is is
extremely important
and
because of the um
the effect on the animal and the
effect of 100
oxygen on the animal the
if you go back here
to show you the unit better
the ventilator is built in underneath
the display
screen
and uh
and then all the pneumatics are inside
and the
air to the animal comes out the
integrated digital vaporizer block
and then it returns through the other
port
are there any other questions i think we
have our
presentation time
he's here
well we hope that um
the presentation was informative
it's uh
the important part about the
smaller anesthesia system is that it
only uses what the animal needs instead
of
using human amounts of anesthetic and
trying to just siphon off a little bit
of that to deliver to the animal
okay we have a question from
uh
russell higby from sanofi
uh pasteur vax design corporation how
many different vapors
may be used with the salmonella suite
actually any
uh liquid uh
anesthetic uh vapor that will be
vaporized that has a vapor temperature
of
a vaporization temperature over 30 could
be used in the in the um
in the salmon suite the current unit is
set up for both iso and sibo fluorine
but as long as we know the molecular
weight and the vaporization temperature
uh we do
the somnisweet does a molar calculation
of the amount of air that's going out
through the vaporizer block
and with that we calculate the number of
moles of the anesthetic that are needed
to be delivered to the airstream
uh to make a certain percentage
and then when we test that we run that
against a test uh the test equipment it
it's right on it's dead on
a question who can uh
who can maintain this unit
uh
is ken scientific the only one that can
service the unit uh we are the only
company this is from excusing moya holly
again at lethbridge
we are the only company that
manufactures the sauna suites
yes that's correct we have them on the
shelf all the time
but typically the unit does not require
calibration because it's uh all
digitally calculated
through the sensors and such uh and the
sensors are all uh pre-calibrated
flow sensors and such so they're
reproducible
and
the maintenance on it you would re
annual maintenance requires that you
replace
the vaporization fret which is just on
the inside of the block and which is a
filter
that we supply but it's
a center disk
this is from russell higby from santa fe
again is it uh
is it programmable by the end user the
system
uh
the
sumner suite is has a full menu
system
and you can go into almost every
parameter and set it so the user can set
the type of anesthesia the size of the
syringe the temperature of the vaporizer
block
you can determine whether you're going
to turn the anesthesia system on or off
if you want to
and such so and as far as the ventilator
goes all of that is settable even though
we try to make the ventilator simple the
ventilator
uh by entering just the animal's weight
the user can go in and adjust any
parameter on the ventilator
we have a question from from
from pedro fiera fiera from fmup
can the ventilator
data be inputted to some kind of
software like lab chart uh
80 instruments who makes power lab was
nice enough to make and we worked worked
with us and we made a um
a bridge uh so that uh
we
excuse me in our units we put in a lab
chart interface and so you can download
a free
uh from the zomnis suite in the physio
suite and the coda monitor that kent
scientific makes all have the lab chart
interface
and lab chart will automatically log
connect to the devices and
we
collect data from them
a question from
piero
we did that one okay
um
so okay so anyway it's there what do we
have down here another question excuse
me
did i this is from
murray horn from csu east bay
and said did i understand correctly that
room air can be used as a method of
administration administrating the gas
sorry the rest of the question is
are is is there any benefits and i'm
clicking on this which is supposed to
show me the full answer but
i don't know if the answer is longer
than that
uh did i okay so room air can be used as
administration of gas yes the the
samno suite
has a built-in air pump
and delivers flow gas or air flow rates
up to 500 milliliters per minute
so you can you can
switch just by going into the first menu
system i think it's the fourth menu
selection down on the main menu it
determines how you're going to use it
and
with the standard vaporizer
some sweet vaporizer you can use
compressed gas or room air and if you're
using room air it uses the internal pump
otherwise it uses the compressed gas
on the back
we recommend that the you know that the
compressed gas be anywhere from five to
ten psi
if you only have it if you only have a
high pressure source we do have
um a small drop down
regulator that can be used on the back
and
you can also use the compressed gas to
drive the ventilator uh
as well as the room air to drive the
ventilator
what's the maximum length of time that
the unit uh can be used for
is it
is it possible to re um
to refill the anesthetic
in mid-stream
well our
we uh
for a mouse
typically you can run a good four hours
on a two ml of isofluorine if you're
using cereal fluorine which takes a
higher percentage it would be less than
that but for isofluorine you can run two
um like i said two hours
four hours on two mls or about 0.5 ml
per hour so if you put a 5ml syringe in
there
you could go almost 10 hours on it um
we like to have the flow rate a little
bit higher and yes you can fill it in
in mid stream
you can pop these
we recommend perhaps is to have a second
syringe if it's going to if you think
you're going to have to fill it in
midstream
have a second syringe
that's filled just uh pop the empty
syringe out you tell the
the unit to
re to fill itself which automatically
moves the plunger block back to the
filled position drop the new syringe in
connect the tubing to it and you're
ready to go
uh
so
another question from matthew
reigel
from
uh
university of texas i believe ut
southwestern
uh vaporizer calc uh calibration is
required of anesthetic of anesthetic
machines at our institution
is uh
how is the calibration of your vaporizer
uh we use the
uh you have to excuse me that the
questions aren't all coming through here
uh beyond two lines so
but i'll answer it the best i can
okay i'm sorry i'm showing up down here
i'm new to the command here
okay
what is your recommendation on how the
unit is calibrated
we
periodically calibrate the units or test
the units for calibration
with a reikin
uh anesthesia monitor which is uh
which we purchased from a company called
um
uh
right i forgot the name of the company
well it's a it's a it's a typical sensor
that's used for calibrating uh
vaporizers
the
and it every time that we've done it if
we set it for two and a half percent and
we run it through the monitor it's two
and a half percent um
and we were doing that on the prototype
units to make sure our math was correct
and the first time we ran it it was that
way so because this is like calibrating
uh an excel spreadsheet essentially
so
what you can do is take the unit set it
for a
um
a certain value the flow rates tend to
be a little bit low for the
for this for the right consensus so you
have to make sure that you use at a
higher flow rate
and you can test it every year
but it's not required
the calibration again is like
calibrating an excel spreadsheet so i
don't know how you calibrate an excel
spreadsheet except trust that it's
doing its mathematics correctly
uh
any other questions
again excuse me for being a little rough
but
hopefully i've answered all of your
questions um
the
system itself uh fits very well we're at
a presentation i didn't i haven't seen
marcel's presentation this this time but
we're at a presentation two weeks ago at
the university of
pennsylvania a similar type of
presentation in which marcel was the op
was the keynote speaker
and
he was very
very emphatic about monitoring the
variables and controlling the variables
of animal anesthesia
and for surgery so that your data from
your experiments can
can be valid and reproducible
and that's the same thing that we've
tried to do as a company can scientific
for animals because we know how
important research is
and i'm not
and so we've made it a
focus on our company to try to do things
that are non-invasive
and allow the
user to or the researcher to control
external variables in the animal
uh
thank you it's been
great to be with you and
we hope it's this has been of service